nu à suivre cette situation après
l'invasion russe de l'ukraine
nous allons tout de suite retrouvé tarek
kayes en direct de l'elysée où s'est
tenue ce matin un conseil de défense
exceptionnelle que peut-on retenir tarek
un conseil de défense dont qui a débuté
à 9 heures ce matin et qui a duré
environ une heure trente qui a eu lieu
au pc jupiter lieux ultra-sécurisés ici
à l'elysée donc le président macro avait
convoqué ce sommet ou à ce conseil de
défense en présence du premier ministre
jean castex du ministre des affaires
étrangères arménien de la ministre
désarmé et également donc du nist
d'économie bruno le maire ou du ministre
de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin il s'agissait donc avant
tout de faire le point sur
l'organisation à venir à la suite de
l'offensive ukrainienne et de planifier
les actions à prendre à court terme au
niveau européen et international pad
annonce majeure de la part de l'elysée
puisque un message une extrême fermeté
sera adressée aujourd'hui même lors du
conseil européen qui aura lieu à
bruxelles à 20h autre réunion importante
c'est celle du g7 qui aura lieu en
visioconférence à 15 heures en ce qui
concerne le président est mignonne mâcon
il pourra prendre la parole aujourd'hui
même c'est ce qu'affirme l'elysée sans
préciser toutefois là à l'heure exacte
de la prise de parole du président de la
république le présent mâcon donc qui
fera entendre à la voix de la france est
celle de l'union européenne cela
pourrait intervenir avant le à l' union
du conseil européen où avant même la
réunion du g7 à 15 heures au niveau de
l'agenda international un sommet de
l'otan par aussi avoir lieu d'ici demain
c'est une demande de la part de la
france qui est également appuyé par
l'allemagne et l'italien ce qui concerne
ce conseil de défense dont qui a eu lieu
beaucoup de questions restent en suspens
y aura-t-il de nouvelles sanctions
économiques beaucoup plus sévères à
l'égard de la russie y aura-t-il un
soutien logistique aux mêmes une aide
militaire on en sera davantage avec
justement cette prise de paroles
solennelles du président de la
république qui devrait intervenir
aujourd'hui même merci beaucoup tarek
caïds